closure of some kind for families and
friends of five
cyclists killed after they were hit by a
man driving a box truck
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis that crash
happened in december on 95 near
searchlight the driver
jordan barson sentenced to a minimum of
16 years in prison
i pray you receive the maximum sentence
because that is not enough it will never
be enough
now the sentence consists of two
sentences each
eight to 20 years to be served
consecutively
barson pled guilty to two counts of dui
resulting in death
and admitted he had meth in his system
when he ran into the group
orco mana is live tonight orco this is a
tragedy you've been close to ever since
it happened back in december
how are friends and families coping
tonight
well brian cycling advocates say there
is no sentence length for barson
that can bring back those who were
killed the community is focused on
creating positive change through
education and legislation
and they've already made some progress
i care and love them and i think about
them all the time a community is still
grappling with
grief robert hutchinson was friends with
the cyclists who were tragically killed
last december on u.s 95
hutchinson president of the southern
nevada bicycle coalition immediately got
to work
increasing education across las vegas we
decided to
come up with a campaign to help do
safety and awareness for
bicyclists and pedestrians in the valley
in january they launched the change
lanes for bikes campaign urging drivers
to follow the law
by changing lanes or giving at least
three feet of space when passing
cyclists i have seen a lot of progress
in the in the last six months steps
forward have also been taken at the
county and state level
we've been also restriping roads in
addition to widening lanes clark county
commissioner justin jones says the
county has clarified the three-feet rule
that a cyclist can take the full lane
when there's not a shoulder or it's
otherwise
dangerous for them to train ride on the
right side of the road and governor
steve sisolak recently signed senate
bill 285
into law which would require driver's ed
courses to not only focus on cars
the rules on cycling safety are
incorporated hutchinson says there's
still a lot of work to do when it's all
to achieve
one goal is making sure that our
community
are safe so i don't have to lose any
more friends
the county is also working to create
more bike paths in the valley
for example they're working with the blm
to build trails out in the red rock area
commissioner jones tells me the first
leg of that project
is expected to begin construction next
year reporting live in las vegas tonight
orca mana 8 news now